what's up dudes
I'm Ryan right yeah and dudettes I'm
Jerry Ghostbusters have returned people
the long anticipated sequel that we
thought we'd get all three characters
back again rooted for that four years
didn't happen or four well no one really
counts Ernie Hudson yeah they do people
know Ernie Hudson's name who counts
Ernie Hudson a lot of people do and it's
not because he's white ghostbusters
official trailer number one rebooting it
with a female cast Kristen Wiig a
Melissa McCarthy from bridesmaids
director Paul Feig Figgy Kevin [ __ ]
yeah Kevin Kevin Feige directions as
soon as I turned the speaker on I have
some concerns about this movie dan yeah
I mean I love the original ghosts but
we'll talk more about it we'll talk more
about it later we'll talk more about it
later where he acting like that's
annoying thing didn't know it's not like
this movie is is boggling people's minds
in a way that to me is weird because
nobody talks about this movie the same
way they talk about any other movie so
are you for it yeah I love how when a
movie has a lot of love you express so
much doubt when a movie has doubt you
expressed nothing but love yeah but love
I mean okay like a I don't absolutely
love bridesmaids Gary let's just watch
the trailer you're taking forever
talking about your nonsense thanks
spider-man
I know this was ghostbusters this would
be funnier there's a class for
oppression that's okay she seems
peaceful my name is Aaron Gilbert doctor
particle physics that's step one
everywhere by the way in every crack
very hard to wash off we have dedicated
our whole lives to studying the
paranormal
now there's sightings all over the city
there are people out there that need our
housing
Holtzman you're a brilliant engineer
Aaron no one's better at quantum physics
than you we can provide a real service
I'm joining the club you guys are really
smart around science stuff but I know
New York and I can borrow a car from my
uncle disclose that the vehicle was
gonna be a hearse
let's go let's go oh did you want to
race I like to LA do next time someone
is creating a device Hey Paranormal
Activity they might be the only ones who
can stop it
Holtzman come on the Hat is too much
right
is it the wigger than hell
alright there's a bigger picture and
here these ghosts can possess the human
form
I feel the exact same way I felt before
watching this trailer yeah this did it
amplify any feelings or minimize
anything the one cool thing that I got
from it was I'm glad they're still
making it a horror comedy yeah you know
because Ghostbusters wanted to our
horror comedies when I heard the
director they were getting when I heard
the cast I was like okay that makes
sense because Ghostbusters is really a
comedy as well however will it be scary
and spooky at the same time it's cool to
see the visual effects are updated but
they're still honoring sort of the
original designs of the ghosts yeah it
has a certain you know looks a little
yeah cartoony in a good way like in a in
a fun way
yeah yeah no Slimer is a cartoony
looking guy and all the ghosts kind of
have that even the humanoid ones sort of
have a fantastical yeah to them and all
the weapons and stuff look cool oh yeah
I feel like the action scenes will be
cool I feel like the probably topped the
original in terms of technicality you
know it's like people always compare the
Star Wars fights like oh the prequels
are better but to me they're like way
too hyper stylized yeah good cast it's a
great cast not like oh I think I'll for
this ship a real fun Ghostbusters is
something so special to me and I don't
feel this looks special somebody pointed
this out to me and and I and I just did
because of what this movie isn't because
of the controversy surrounding it
there's a lot of other Ghostbusters [ __ ]
that's not very good that nobody
complains about except everyone's
complaining about this well when it
comes to the movies though that's the
thing that make ghostbusters 2
forgivable was the cast because it's
still the same returning team that we
love and this is a whole new set of
characters and they don't look as
appealing I don't agree with that
entirely I get where you're going with
this and it is true cuz it's like a
halfway for me it's like I feel like you
can do Ghostbusters without the cast
because you have the idea you have the
world you have the machines you have all
those ideas and you can theoretically
plug other characters into that if you
do it properly but it's not like
this example before it's not like Point
Break we're like there's no point unless
you have Keanu Reeves and Patrick Swayze
an island like this I think it can work
and the only complaint I have about this
trailer is the same complaint I have
about every comedy trailer is just like
I have a hard time laughing at comedy
trailers cuz it's all jokes with no
context so sometimes they look more
annoying or more you know kind of too
much improv I gotta give it to them that
the director Melissa McCarthy of
collabed on like four movies they know
how to put together some pretty strong
films like their films are all pretty
good for the most part I'm not sure if
this is their fourth one or fifth one
amides made spy heat their films are all
pretty good for the most part I'm not
sure if this is their fourth one or
fifth one I made spy heat I like some
Paul figs other work I mean freaks and
geeks is incredible I mean if you're
gonna do a female cast this is the right
female cast to do my only concerns for
this movie for me are just like the same
concerns I have with any one of these
comedies are we gonna actually keep
things moving along and sort of you know
moderate so that it works as a comedy
but can still move as a movie instead of
just being one longer yeah but the idea
I I think is cool and and the action II
bits like the really Ghostbuster II
stuff in this trailer does excitement I
hope one thing this movie does is give
us a damn good villain cuz even go
ghostbusters ii wasn't as well-received
the villain was still pretty scary the
painting and all the head dude from
whatever time century he was right yeah
he was scary and then you know what's
the quote from ghostbusters woman do
there is no Dana yeah they're a bunch of
Easter eggs in this trailer by the way
because yeah you know Dana and what's
Rick Moranis his name the gatekeeper guy
there's like a little reference to both
of those characters in one of the shots
there's a website hidden in this trailer
there's all kinds of well the shot would
the three of them in the opening of the
trailer and the ghost screaming at them
is omage to the beginning of the first
Ghostbusters except this ghost is like
throwing up on them and stuff yeah but a
slime thing is another amage to the
ghostbusters it's garnering the same
post-world I bet it's not just a reboot
that it's a sequel as well I think that
was actually confirmed that it's also
same I I think yeah it's like it takes
place on the same timeline just farther
and it's a sequel with different
characters thirty years later cuz I
think dad Aykroyd or somebody is
supposed to appear and yeah like and I
and I the other reason I forgiving this
movie too is because that isn't Bill
Murray the one who's like that I give
you Ghostbusters trio yeah I know but I
don't feel like we need more
ghostbusters
I don't feel like we need it but as long
as we're getting it I'd rather have
something like this where it's like oh
you're doing something marginally
different you know you see people might
not agree with me on this but
Ghostbusters is one of those classics
where I'm like shouldn't be touched
I love Ghostbusters but I don't I don't
necessarily agree with you it's like The
Godfather
no it's not it's like Casablanca it's
not like that at all
it's it's like Citizen Kane no like I'd
rather see a reboot of eclectic shifters
then Ghostbusters really yeah really
I'd rather see a reboot of Reservoir
Dogs with an all-female cast I mean not
that we should just like for the sake of
all female ever ething do that but hey I
don't know just the idea seems gimmicky
I disagree
in a way like it isn't it isn't because
I think like yeah we should be able to
have an all-female Ghostbusters and not
have it be an issue and it's become such
an issue that like it is gimmicky only
in the sense that like it's a bold move
that people will react you're never not
gonna have at least in this version of
society you're never you're not gonna
have people being what the [ __ ] all
female Ghostbusters what is this I think
it's a necessary step forward and I hope
that this movie is fun along with that
two things all I mentioned Chris
Hemsworth mm-hmm I love seeing serious
actors go into comedy roles like that
granted we don't know what it is he's
doing necessarily here's the secretary
yeah but we don't know exactly how his
character portrayal is gonna go down we
need certain qualities that I really
feel need to be super strong here we
need the Ghostbusters to have great
chemistry we need them to be funny and
this movie also needs to be scary
I feel like this film totally has the
potential to do all three yeah
I don't know maybe I'm just
superstitious is I something tells me
I'm gonna be wrong in the end I thought
spy looked like crap and then I watched
it I was like this is a great comment I
don't think this looks like crap I'm
just I just have concerns I understand
what you mean worried I mean I'm worried
for it too but again it's like I'm not
against the idea I just hope that they
execute it properly because like I said
the worries I have are the same worries
I have whenever I hear the name Paul
Feig or whatever I hear the name Melissa
McCarthy and and I actually like what
her character looks like in this cuz she
doesn't look like the same oh she's fat
and loud like she actually looks like a
different carrot Kong you know she looks
calmer she's the scientist right yeah
she looks like she's actually allowed to
be a character instead of look it's the
funny fat chick who says outlandish
things like well they're all filling
them for the art types of what they were
in the first Ghostbusters - they're just
female versions even got Ernie Hudson
back yeah they got Ernie Hudson back I
did they might have I can't I can't
remember I can't keep all the news in
drag I don't know I thought hurting
Hudson called weathers are the same
person growing up for most of my life
you really yeah that's horrible okay
Ernie Hudson died and predator is a
really sad day and I thought I was Carl
Weathers okay we'll still definitely be
checking it out this is just speculation
so when the movie comes out I'll give
you my honest opinion and no I don't go
in with a closed mind I go in ready to
be moved and changed I'm willing to be
subscribe today get rejected yeah you're
not a lot of subscribe so that we can
sit you back in email it's like hey
thanks you know thanks thanks you are
not allowed to be part of the
subscription service provided by YouTube
on the real rejection we control Jerry
has a playlist on here called reasons to
Jerry featuring all the videos from said
Jerry and he has a podcast hosted with
his buddy Aaron called dank ass Stubbs
as buddy as his number 2 best friend I'm
his number 1 and shout out to obesity
what I think obesity is always getting a
bad rep these days and I think we should
be a little nicer to obesity obesity has
feelings too people they're not just
swallowed they have feelings so don't
insult people's
where's of how heavy they somewhere in
there is a sentiment worth holding on to
and I think it just needs a little more
refining just a little more a couple
more drafts and we can hop on board with
that you know my favorite moment and
Ghostbusters one is what is that when
the creepy ghost [ __ ] how about you
stop assuming and you just let me know
all right no no I tell me please I want
to tell you please tell me cameras go